on nbc tonight the rebooted
the weakest link it's gonna be every
tuesday night at eight
eastern time and the host is the lady
who put the glee and glee
she puts the marvelous in the marvelous
mrs maisel and most importantly as we
all know
helped dr richard kimball figure out
who switched the samples samples
and saved the day in the fugitive she is
none other than the four-time
emmy award winner jane lynch back here
on the rich eisen show how are you jane
i'm so good i love that you referenced
the liver sample mystery from
the future awesome come on
jane let's not forget that way before
you won all of these awards
that was a very without you i mean
richard campbell might still be in jail
if i'm not mistaken be still on the run
can you imagine you'd be like seven
pounds
and still on the line but still exactly
and and we don't need that
we know we needed we needed we needed
the finish that we needed
exactly indeed who bobby lee jones would
have been still chasing after him maybe
so tired at this point
exactly i by the way that is
maybe one it's in one of my top five
remote drop movies the fugitive
literally has caused me to miss
appointments
not going where i need to go i mean what
it's just it's just a remote job
so well done it's such a well-done movie
absolutely i'm
very honored that i had a little part in
it one of my first movie roles
now did you was that like chicago ties
that you wound up in that
film yeah you know the woman who was his
uh andy davis's who directed it
right his assistant somehow talked him
into giving me that part
and it was a part originally written for
a guy which is i tend to get a lot of
those parts in my history
and for some reason he cast me he didn't
even meet me he trusted her
exactly i know that but what was it like
for you though to be thrown into a scene
with harrison ford
oh my god you know it's one of those
things it it uh
you're nervous it's like when i work
with meryl streep too
you're nervous you know what you're
getting into and you know that this
these are like the biggest stars in
hollywood and you just have to show up
and do your job
you have to like push all that
nervousness aside and you have to be a
worker among workers you know because if
you go in there as like a fan
it's you're not going to get your job
done so i had the wisdom to know that so
i just showed up and
you know it was actor actor and we got
along very well and he's
not the easiest god get along with um
he and i uh we uh worked some stuff out
together because he didn't like
the script from uh for our scene so we
was raining that day we went into his
trailer
uh and he held the umbrella over my head
okay and we we worked out the uh the
dialogue
and um it was it was a real joy hold on
a second now
so you're saying it's your first job
okay yeah you get this
job one of your first jobs one of your
first film roles okay so you get the gig
jane lynch
and now it's time for the scene and
harrison ford's like this script is
garbage
or something like that and let's you and
i go uh
workshop it that literally happened yeah
that literally happened in my workshop
and it was great
it was so nice to me and you know we
worked out we like
improvised back and forth we figured it
out fantastic
it was nice i mean i actually worked
with him as an actor and there's nothing
like that to like uh
break the spell you just get to work and
then again it just cracked the rdu 90
um code it just cracked the case wide
open oh my gosh you
really you're really repetitive am i
freaking you out right now
a little bit a little bit that's the
name of the drug right that was our
rdu yes dr
nichols lied to tommy lee jones and all
of that stuff
i guess this is my way hank wait for it
wait for it to try and prove to you i'm
not the weakest link when it comes to
this
there we go let's talk about the
important thing that's going on right
now
going down one lane but let's talk about
what's happening right now here and now
the here and now the weakest link
returning to our world
and so you are the host of this project
pretty much is everything absolutely
it's the exact same game because
why mess with percep perfection yes it's
a quiz show it's
rapid fire trivia questions you being a
smart guy thank you
a wide birth of knowledge would love it
so you need to watch it every week and
you need to
play from your couch while you're while
you're watching it
um as you know the reference level of
the questions goes all over the place
it's history it's science
it's math it's uh uh
arts it's literature um and you need
kind of like
a fine general knowledge as well as uh
grace under pressure because the clock
is going
and the stakes are high and uh in terms
of your hosting of it jane uh this is
not your first hosting rodeo as we know
that's
my first rodeo not at all i've i've been
there i've been in the hollywood game
night
set i've i've played it uh without
michaels and uh
everybody i've been there and i've done
that what fun that was
what a great episode that was that was a
ton of fun no doubt about it
so uh but with you hosting this um do
you
channel your inner ann robinson or do
you give you do you give your own
twist on the you are the weakest link
goodbye do you do
your own twist certainly inspired me i
don't know if you watched it when it was
on nbc in the early arts
of course i loved it and i loved
her so i'm sure she inspires me uh on
some level but you know i had to
just i think the the smartest thing i
could do was
you you don't imitate her just do your
own brand
okay so i did my own brand of uh you
know severe school mom which
comes to me kind of easily so i lead
with that
right okay yeah but you don't put a
different accent like you are
the weakest link or you know every once
in a while i do you know what
the uh uh our executive producer stuart
uh whispered in my ear once he said
stress the word weakest so i i did that
if you
you are the weakest link as opposed to
the strongest thing so that works
sometimes you know what
it's organic however i feel it
you know what i'm saying so like your
derision is real
when you're when you're when you're when
you're kicking somebody's ass off
weakest you're weak ass off the show
right i don't even make eye contact with
them i just
miss them and they walk by me and i
don't look at them until they're
going into the tunnel which turns bright
red as they're walking out like
they're going into dante's inferno and
they're walking into the pit of hell and
then i turn around and i stare at the
back of them
i hear you jane lynch because again for
me i'm i'm an aficionado of game shows
and game show host
the move that alex trebek makes when
somebody gets
a question that they should have gotten
right
wrong okay the thing that he does the
thing that he
does is he gives the res he gives the
correct or question or answer however
you want to put it
he doesn't make eye contact he reads the
correct response off of a card
and circles it or exes it out
with his uh marker and the squeaking
noise that it makes
is to me thoroughly intentional i i do
not think it's unintentional at all
he is so smooth and so good and so
straight
yes there's nothing going on so he does
the slightest smoulder
and it goes right through you right
through you see you know
you know oh i know how to do
[Laughter]
he's that on their toes they want to
please me so badly
of course you don't they don't want to
be allowed they don't want to be the
weakest link because otherwise then
that's goodbye for them i mean you don't
need to do that
now starts tonight at eight eastern on
nbc and
episodes will be available right here on
peacock uh the following day
as well uh do you keep in touch with
deandre hopkins from the commercial that
you did
jane you and deandre keep in touch at
all or no
what commercial is that oh my god you're
blowing my mind it was deandre hopkins
yeah
right wasn't that deandre in the nfl
commercial that you did james
oh my god
you know what's funny is we didn't do it
together oh my god
sure you did no you're sure you did it
in one spot he did it another they added
it together
i mean exactly that's right oh my god
how embarrassing
i'm looking at the bottom line what is
this and if i don't care what's the
bottom line how much you know
i just didn't know i didn't know if you
were in a fantasy league or anything
like so that sort of thing no
i have not this is terrible i shouldn't
say this on your show but i have not
paid attention to
football since 1985 when the bears won
the super bowl and then they broke my
heart for the next couple of years and
then i just gave up i moved to los
angeles and i didn't
uh i have no no more affinity well at
least you went out with a blaze of glory
i mean that's one that's only one of the
best teams of all time
i mean i loved them loved every one of
them i knew everything about every one
of them so you must have loved the
the super bowl shuffle i'm sure
absolutely i love the refrigerator
number 72
how he could jump uh from the ground all
the way up onto a table
i don't know if you have william perry
if you ever saw him do that
about like 350 pounds and he was able to
dead jump onto the top of the table
unbelievable i did not know that must
have been a very strong table
yeah yes it would have to be the punky
qb
jim mcmahon obviously sweetness had a
lacerated kidney in one game and
continued to play
so did wait a minute i think we're going
full circle here
if there's a kidney sample in chicago oh
for god's sake
there's nothing going on there wasn't
jim mcmahon's
was a jim mcmahon sample that got
switched
jane oh my could it couldn't we're
connecting
here like crazy we just went full circle
i don't know how i don't know how i can
ask you another question other than to
say i love her
that's it that's got to be a mic job
right thanks for joining jane you take
care of yourself this is great i always
love our chats and congrats
on on being part of this uh latest
venture for you
in your stellar career i can't wait to
watch it tonight and then
tomorrow if i miss it on peacock thanks
for the call jane you take care you bet
take care of you jane lynch everybody